the german parliament is expected to
approve the country's supply chain law
on friday it aims to make corporations
accountable for every inch
of their supply chains and any rights or
environmental abuses
that take place within them
uighur is picking cotton in china's
xinjiang region
the muslim population here has been
oppressed by beijing for many years
abused put in internment camps and made
to work in forced labor
much of their product used to end up in
shoes and shirts sold in germany and
other western countries
the supply chain law prohibits forced
labor as well as child labour and work
threatening or destroying the
environment
it applies to all companies selling to
germany
and it's met opposition from industry
bodies
is fearful we think it's wrong to
respond to a global problem
with a national law this doesn't change
the global human rights situation
all it does it creates additional
competitive disadvantages
for our own companies here which are
global leaders in terms of their
standards
the standards
the industry argues that german
companies might have to stop doing
business with some countries
making the situation for people they are
even worse
but berlin wants change
for too long we have accepted the
exploitation of people and nature in
developing countries
for too long we have tolerated child
labour on a large scale
children laboring on plantations or in
mines the german government wants to end
all that
and set an example for others in the eu
and beyond
that it can be done well let's get more
on this from our financial correspondent
in frankfurt chelsea delaney chelsea
businesses have argued
this law will be impossible to implement
are they right
well in its purest form it would be very
difficult because the idea
is that a company operating here in
germany would be responsible
from the moment that that raw material
from the moment that cotton or that uh
that metal
comes out of the ground in some far away
uh
but in actuality it's not going to be
that strict of a law for most companies
these
businesses are going to be responsible
for
themselves and their direct suppliers
but
further down the line they're indirect
suppliers they they only have to
uh basically conduct these due diligence
and risk analysis uh procedures if they
get some sort of
tip or a complaint that these human
rights are being violated so
this is still quite difficult for some
companies that haven't been doing this
yet
but this rule will only apply to 0.1
percent of german businesses
we've heard complaints from industry
bodies but it's not totally without
support from the business world is it
right and some of germany's biggest
companies have come out in support of
this
uh companies like daimler and adidas and
in bmw
have called for supply chain laws these
are companies that have to some extent
been
doing this sort of due diligence for
suppliers for a long time
but others are are still quite critical
of this they say especially for the
smaller businesses it's going to be very
difficult to build up
these new reporting systems and of
course many companies are quite worried
that this is going to put them at a
disadvantage when they have all of these
new bureaucratic costs and other
companies around the world don't
so are we expecting other countries to
follow in germany's footsteps
yeah i think many people think germany
will be a trendsetter for this france
already has a supply chain law like this
the eu
has basically promised to come out with
its own version
they had said june so i think we could
expect something like that soon
other countries have made some sort of
move towards supply chain diligence in
the u.s they've
banned the importing of cotton from
xinjiang
and other countries have made steps like
that as well but
i think we're a while away from a really
global
supply chain law like this chelsea
delaney and frankfurt thank you